the news from Newsweek from Newsweek of
all sources I know Republicans tie
Hunter Biden to human trafficking
announce probe let me pause right there
they explicitly stated this is an
investigation of Joe Biden so Newsweek
they're talking about it but they're
trying to you know maybe the goal with
the article is to be like it's Hunter
not Joe right but uh you know I'll be
specific they said they were announcing
an investigation into Joe they didn't
specifically say Joe Biden was
trafficking people although I think he
was with the illegal immigrants yes he
was well okay nevermind he was was this
broken by Geek Squad or who did it which
one it just depends on the source which
which was it a computer that was
returned like who knows where did they
get the Intel uh actually I think it was
um some Republicans in Tennessee who
filmed the children being trafficked on
U.S military planes around the country
by the bite Administration so oh right
no no I I mean he literally was
trafficking children oh good for him I
thought it was was the hunter sex
Russian prostitute thing oh no I mean
yes yeah I don't mean to keep it clean
for the family friendly people watching
it's just they're called ladies of the
night I'm sorry and you know Hunter
Biden did love ladies of the night
particularly from Russia which you know
a lot of people were going crazy about
specifically speculating that Donald
Trump had relations with in some kind of
hotel rooms but but again here we
actually have some real life proof of of
Hunter Biden taking videos and photos of
some absolutely crazy behavior that do
violate a lot of laws Lady of the night
I mean I feel like you know it's it's
archaic maybe something like adult
physical therapists lady who puts down a
tarp
I think a lot of these videos of Hunter
were you know during the day yeah so you
know it you know just adult physical
therapy we'll just call it that you know
some blood into morning I mean literally
bleeding I love that he vlogged the
whole thing too the whole thing is well
documented he's like he's like the new
David dobrik you know he's he's an
artist he he's ahead of his times and
it's really incredible you know the Sim
simota Verte that he presented to the
general public truly an artist of our of
our time my favorite is the Eminem photo
a member of his with M M's yep
and Hunter took a picture of it he was I
don't want to look at those pictures
I was like this is gonna be my wallpaper
I did okay well let's let's let's let's
see what they're talking about well
they're specifically looking into a
number of charges they're looking to see
if they could charge them with
conspiracy or defrauding the United
States why are fraud conspiracy to
commit wire fraud violation of the
foreign agents registration act
violation of the foreign corruption
Practices Act violation of the victims
of trafficking and violence protection
act of 2000 tax evasion money laundering
and conspiracy to commit money
laundering those are the charges those
are what they're looking into Joe uh I I
think Hunter and Joe since uh this
Newsweek article this Newsweek article
talks about how they had bank accounts
that were co-mingled together uh they
obviously also shared phone numbers they
obviously also were in business together
it's pretty clear no matter how many
times Joe Biden tries to deny this it's
very clear that there was a lot of
communication a lot of back and forth
business dealings a lot of Air Force too
a lot of lucrative contracts in Ukraine
and in China that he was not supposed to
get that he got along of course with his
vlogging of smoking crack being with
ladies of the night and having firearms
everywhere one firearm that he left
outside of a school zone which he got in
trouble for in a trash can in a trash
can thank you at least he tried to hide
it I just wanna I just want to simplify
the way George tried to hide a cannoli
on Seinfeld I just wanna I just want to
simplify this for everybody really quick
um
outside of all of this I'm sure there's
gonna be a bunch of people on the left
or you know Democrats desperately trying
to defend Joe being like this is
nonsense it's fake news it's so
Preposterous but they shared bank
accounts and right there is the is the
morsel of whoa whoa whoa cause let me
tell you something yo I tried to buy my
mom like a toaster and my account is
like you can't do that like you you
cannot have like you you give something
to somebody it is a gift it is tracked
it goes towards that if you share a bank
account you're making it like basically
impossible to track how much you're
giving to another person there's no
circumstance where I I guess if if Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden were both
officers of a corporation or some some
something like that and they both had
executive access to a bank account that
could make sense but hey hold on there a
minute that would mean that Joe Biden
lied and was directly involved in
business with his son otherwise it just
sounds like some weird at the very least
tax evasion or you know income
commingling which is already a problem
the human trafficking is definitely
related to the ladies of the night he
was he he bought a lot of them and
especially from Eastern Europe who knows
if some people might speculate that he
was swallowed uh that's also another
possibility here but but
he was picking them out like it was a
Wendy's menu he was saying I don't like
this one you know take the lettuce off
of that one he really wanted picking
them out on these text messages it was
well documented yeah but Jim I do want
to say you said the left is going to
come out and say it's not true I don't
know that they're going to say much of
anything to be honest yeah I think
they're just going to ignore it because
that's what they do when they these
things come out that there's a mountain
of evidence they just ignore it hey at
least though did they well who knows you
know I think there were a lot of them
yeah exactly how much Intel are you
going to get with really just a half
hour each yeah but but the caveat here
at least we give big Tech social media
something to censor in the future just
like the hunter Biden laptop story at
least now we're gonna have the sensors
at Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
busy with more work so at least you know
they're gonna have something to do I
hear you but I'm actually kind of
optimistic you know Facebook came out
and said they're not going to be fact
checking Trump's campaign because he's
running or something like that Elon Musk
buys Twitter
so I'm kind of like I think I think
maybe they they you know the the the
extremists shot their shot and and they
can't keep that up at a certain point
you're trying to hold back a day like a
a river and the damn bursts yes you know
they censor everything we all know the
scandal of the hunter Biden laptop
censorship they they can't pull that off
again I mean can they well it's filled
with everything he just said
with Republicans controlling the house
if all we get is Nancy Pelosi is fired
and they launched his investigation this
investigation alone is going to make it
impossible YouTube took down C-SPAN
videos of Rand Paul talking because he
said a naughty name no now if they're
all saying it they can't just if YouTube
started Banning C-SPAN outright people
might be like hey wait a minute they
took down one video and hope nobody
noticed they took down a Fox News video
and hoped that nobody's nobody nobody
noticed but if they if they're going to
have a committee putting out videos if
they're gonna have a January 6 style
inquiry ain't nothing they can do about
it we'll see spin after dark's pretty
hot I hope they do a j6 trial for this
you know a stock a j6 style
investigation they should do the whole
nine they should put the hunter Biden
laptop contents on the screen for the
whole world to sing I don't know exactly
absolutely evidence it's all there it's
all vlogged by Hunter Biden on truck
it's all there that's a lot to see
though my my favorite C-SPAN after dark
was when all the all the Democrats
called in saying they were quitting the
party you guys remember that that was
crazy it was a few years ago but it was
just like I remember pulling the video
up and pressing play and it was just a
guy being like I don't know what they're
doing they lost their minds I'm voting
Republican now and I'm like wow but
there's also a possibility that we might
find something even more Sinister I
think there's a big probability for this
as well because when we look at what's
been happening throughout the last few
years the FBI knew a lot of this was
happening they had the laptop they had
interviews with Tony bobolinski they
chose to of course censor and cover it
up what was inside of that laptop what
are also the very weird photos with
children inside of that laptop which I I
think is something that could
essentially be something that will shock
the American public to the point where
there's no returning from it and I think
there's a possibility of that happening
maybe the maybe the game is to slow roll
it to the point where everyone's heard a
little bit without getting shocked too
much so when they when they finally come
out and admit it everyone's gonna be
like well yeah dude we know well they
also rated giuliani's house and he's
like it's right here and they're like no
we came for everything else yep yeah
where she had the laptop he had the
hunter Biden laptop with the weird
photos of the the children yeah let's be
honest here it would have been funny if
it would have been sorry it would have
been funny if they were arrested
Giuliani for possession yeah
they're like oh you got those images but
there's
but you got it yeah it's on you it's not
just Hunter though it's also I mean that
whole family's Disturbed all of his
children are very disturbed her a lot
the Ashley Biden diary was one of the
most disturbing things I ever read and
after I read it I felt bad yeah
but I don't think we could read it
online today
she talks about showering with her
father that whole family is disturbing
right my grandfather Yeah she talked
about how she had to shower at night
because she was afraid Biden was going
to come into the shower with her yeah
yes that's what is it in there what if
when Biden broke his leg it wasn't the
dog but like his granddaughter
or some kind of child fighting back be
like no could be who knows nowadays
especially with you know the island that
they all go to especially you know since
the island closed down they gotta you
know I think he was probably just
fighting back the nurses he's like don't
put it in again I'm ready to go
powdery bones and that man is not filled
with calcium remember when uh during the
Alex Jones trial the prosecution was
like you think that that powerful Global
Elites are trafficking children and he
goes what you mean like Epstein and they
did with the clintons and then they made
the thug life video now if anyone ever
brings that up they're like oh you
believe some weird conspiracy about you
know Elites trafficking people I'll be
like you mean like the investigation the
Republicans have opened into the Biden
family yeah like look you can call it a
conspiracy but then you gotta you have
to contend with the fact that the
majority of Congress is investigating
that so yeah they're a cult like I I
rewatched that Sam Harris clip where
he's like there is nothing on the hunter
Biden laptop that is bad as Trump
University
and I'm like my guy there's like illicit
pictures of children you're saying that
Donald Trump scammed some people out of
cash the bidens are implicated in human
trafficking Sam Harris he lost his mind
yeah yeah absolutely and like you
compare the two there's no comparison
what about Trump's Stakes
[Laughter]
actually and you know you know it's
funny too I remember I wasn't serious
well no no look during Trump's campaign
they were saying that all of his
businesses failed and it was the
weirdest thing they were like what
happened to Trump water what happened to
Trump Stakes or Trump magazine and I was
sitting in Trump Doral in Florida
looking at a bottle of trump water with
a trump magazine and a menu showing
Trump steak and I'm like do these people
not understand the companies he started
our suppliers for his his hotels like he
doesn't sell Trump's stake in the
grocery store he's making his own stuff
so he lowers his costs right it's it's
just so insane and I think out of like
500 businesses five went bankrupt and so
they're like look at all those
bankruptcies it's okay dude you believe
you Google it okay come on they don't
they don't even do that no it's sad very
sad when you have other billionaires
that were just kind of mad about it
because he was president and it was kind
of watched it was fun to watch them
project how angry they were because I
didn't think it would happen she just
had like Mark Cuban like it's all failed
you're Mark Cuban thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time